all right you ready for this well yeah i
i am ready you got a trivia question for
me it's goats in a bad way draft i was
going to say something else but i'll
save it for one of my picks go ahead
okay here we go goats in a bad way prior
to sunday
who was the last qb to throw a td
to jordan reed jordan reed saving the
49ers george kittle's injury
came from washington who was that last
washington quarterback to throw him a
touchdown
well
i i know what you're trying to do to me
i'm not stupid
i i i i may work with stupid but i'm not
stupid i'm not trying to do anything
it's got to be kirk cousins it's got to
be it's got to be kirk nope you're
trying to no i thought you tried to
stick the knife into my ribs about kirk
cousins i wasn't yeah we we were not
it's not it's not always about trying to
get you we got uh we got colt mccoy colt
mccoy was the last person wow to throw a
touchdown pass
uh what year
i don't know i didn't i wasn't applied
that it wasn't in 2018 maybe gotta be 18
right i would think so that makes sense
all right
um
i think that i got to start out with
goats in a bad way i i mean this is this
is easy i gotta start with dan quinn and
dan quinn in the atlanta falcons i'm
sorry i mean there's things to like
about your football team through two
weeks but man there's a lot to not like
okay and you know when you're a
defensive head coach and your defense is
getting gashed
both weeks where quarterbacks look like
whoa this is seven on seven football
yeah and you blow a 20 to nothing lead
and you're a defensive head coach and oh
yeah you've blew a lead in a big game
once before
let alone just some of the plays and of
course the way the onside kick unfolded
and everything
um
like dan quinn the guy but damn he's
he's the goat of the week in a bad way
uh in a lot of ways
and here's the thing last year arthur
blank the owner of the team stuck with
dan quinn even though they were abysmal
at the break one in seven after eight
games they finished six and two and
quinn came back but when quinn comes out
in the aftermath of the game and says my
players understand the rule for onside
kicks and the owner
goes on siriusxm nfl radio and says i
it's obvious from the video our players
didn't know the rule
that's not good and that doesn't bode
well for the future of dan quinn they've
got a later buy this week or this year
rather they play the panthers twice
before the buy they've got some games
that they can win to bump up their
record but i guess it's possible you
know they could have four wins at the
break and there could still be a change
made when you've got two former head
coaches on your staff raheem morris runs
the defense although the defensive
performance no feather in his cab no uh
and dirk cutter runs the offense i guess
he would be the candidate to take over
if it came down to it so yeah that was
high on my list but uh i i thought that
the question was pointing toward kirk
cousins because
sorry kirk yeah you can't get that big
raise you can't get that new contract
you can't get all that extra guaranteed
money and have a passer rating lower
than 70. he's been abysmal this year and
we are seeing
something that you and i talked about
the the dividing line between the great
quarterbacks and the the good
quarterbacks right and that is the
ability to make something happen when
the play that's called goes to crap he
has no mobility he has no ability to
recognize that things are falling apart
and react to it i think that's as big of
a problem
as his lack of
escapability yeah first your brain has
to recognize that that the walls are
closing in
and he freezes up we've seen it now in
consecutive weeks and the vikings have
three straight regular season games
dating back to week 17 of last year
where they've allowed a safety and two
weeks this year both times it's kirk
cousins dropping back
and here comes the defender and kirk
doesn't know what to do
that
is not
you know a valuable trait for a
quarterback no you want someone who's
going to see that guy coming and do
something not just fetal position you've
got to do something you've got to be
able to get away from that guy and first
you've got to recognize the need to get
away from that guy so those two plays
are just a microcosm of what's going on
here and yes stefan digs being gone look
it's the julio jones factor remember
when matt ryan got 30 million a year
julio jones got upset and it's like i'm
he's not twice the player i am yeah he's
not twice as important as i am and
not a coincidence the day that kirk
cousins got his new contract is the day
stefan diggs made his push to get out of
minnesota because i think he realizes
that the receivers there have a lot to
do with the success that kirk cousins
had in his first two years with the team
yeah well and you know i also as we sit
here i start to go man maybe kevin
stovansky was a little bit better on the
offensive side of the ball than we
wanted to give him credit for it too
you know that kirk cousins it's not been
good i mean you said it there's no doubt
about it and he is he's the type of
quarterback that needs a system his
greatest asset is his ability to make a
quick decision
and assess a defense and be able to do
all that and pull the trigger and throw
the ball accurately when he doesn't have
a system or anything to expose or not
being caught taught the right way
you're taking away really the greatest
thing he has i mean that's why guys like
mcveigh and shanahan love kirk cousins
because they can just go i can put all
in these crazy plays and he'll do
exactly what i told them well i promise
you he's doing exactly what gary kubiak
told them the problem is gary kubiak's
offense is in the stone ages i don't
know any other way to say it it's still
1997 mike shanahan denver and bronco's
offense and yeah that was an awesome
offense in 1997.
twenty five and when you had john elway
and when you had john elway who could
get away from that
davis and the shanahan run scheme and
everything about that right so
i will question that every bit as much
as kirk cousins and that's where i just
don't know
you know the offense
it's not going to give kirk cousins any
advantages that's for sure and uh it's
not a good look and i don't see how it
rebounds i really don't i i think
they're in deep trouble um
yeah so i don't know good pick by you
hey hey let me let me tell you this
though uh
i'm looking at kirk's contract they're
really stuck they got a 21 million
dollar salary for him next year that's
fully guaranteed and then
in 2022 it's 35 million it becomes fully
guaranteed on the third day of the 2021
league year
um yeah you may want to give kyle a call
after the season
well yeah they may want they may want to
they may want to call kyle and say how
would you like a quarterback that is
perfect for your system more perfect
than jimmy garoppolo well yeah i'm
telling you i'm telling you the way this
thing is going i mean because my i've
said and this is probably what will
happen it'll be treated as a scholarship
year it'll be treated as an aberration
everyone's got security in minnesota by
virtue of the playoff win but man uh
there's a bottom somewhere and they're
cl hopefully for them they're close to
it right because if it gets much worse
than what we've seen the last two weeks
i don't care what kind of job security
is there there's going to be major
changes in minnesota after this season
yeah no doubt about that no doubt it's
uh it's not looking good all right my
next pick all right i think i mean i
want to do the jets full football team
for the crap they look but i think
specifically i have to do the jets
defense let me just say greg williams
i'll just say greg williams that's all i
can really say about it and i i don't
like saying greg williams a whole lot
because it's just like hey there's not a
lot of talent on that jets defense and
everything like that but i'm going to
pick greg williams because of this we
know the 49ers offense was beat up going
into the football game there's no debo
samuel there's no george kittle you know
they're going to run the football i mean
the 49ers ran the football and then some
and like ran for 182 yards and a real
182 yards not like my quarterback
scrambled on a few drop back passes and
ran for 50 something yards in the game
too to add to that stat this was like
running back we're running right at you
but more specifically i come to two
plays that i just i just what i mean the
first play of the game to have a defense
or you don't even touch i mean we made
fun of it on on football night in
america don't even touch raheem mostert
he's not down in a one-hand touch game i
mean to get exposed like that the first
play of the game then there was a third
and 31 where they let up a 50-yard run
and basically untouched and then there
was the first play in the second half
that got called back that was what an
80-yard touchdown 70-yard touchdown so
uh in a game where they needed the
defense and the defense had an advantage
because the 49ers were banged up a
little bit to kind of come through
uh they didn't get off to a good start
and they were down in there all right we
got to keep moving yeah we don't have
much time left we don't want to carry
the draft over until tomorrow i'm going
with
bill
foreign
sorry bill
not calling that time out watch
yesterday's show if you don't know what
i'm talking about bill belichick you get
the goat horns go wow damn you're just
that quick huh okay we still got like a
good minute and 30 left we have a minute
no no we don't go tick tick tick tick
tick i'm going to go with teddy bridge
we can't call time out unlike bill
belichick we can't call timeout buster
teddy bridgewater
driving the ball early in that game he
throws a horrible pick on a screen pass
then they got the oh my god that was
ridiculous right got the game kind of
like in their favor and he's got an open
receiver to the right and throws the
ball uh three feet behind i believe it
was uh dj moore for a big interception
gloves and swamp ass weather don't mix
next one for me i'm torn here
uh
45 seconds hurry up i know i know i
gotta go anthony lynn you don't punt on
fourth and one to patrick holmes
especially when justin herbert was
playing the way he was you don't punt on
fourth and one in overtime go what was i
that was three i picked three things so
i'm done but what is i got
oh you are all right good we're done
yeah but what was your other one you
were weighing out weighing in on mike
mccarthy oh two fake punts and the
ridiculous go for two down nine
ridiculous go for two sorry analytics
guys ridiculous decision to go for two
down nine come after me analytics mafia
i'm i'm confident of one thing even
though i'm 55 i'll kick your butts let's
beat out in the alley
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports